remember when the first like the cells
in the soup now got everywhere for my
brain to the chicken coop ugly the truth
and what I mean to prove is that every
type of living things possibly produces
from E coli the Baltimore Rios I can see
the sale there if I'm looking close my
scope though to help me take a look kind
of like muck she'll shout-out the hook
scribbled in my lab look babe some
oxidation sales come from other cells
that's correlations whether
microscopical the size of the ship
living things gotta eat looks like I as
an individual respond to the environment
over generations pop the ball with the
trial live butter fighting viruses and
battle box alive how are we gonna find
out investigation i'm using little bit
if the mega cell is it living is it
lived in man how we gonna find out if
destination shine the scientist be with
a clean stuff it's not just Baxter doing
things ask me questions first to this
would be your opportunity this is your
first right guys listen to let it move
you everyone so yeah like I said EE
materials to work on that later thanks
so much